nach der dürre jetzt regen ohne ende und
das mit voller wucht martina und wer ist
er in der toskana ganz italien in
piombino etwa zwei stunden von florenz
entfernt dort nicht bloß starkregen
sondern ein tornado der dieses joggen
rad durchdrehen bilder gerade nicht da
hören gerade hier zeigen wir ihnen
gleich das sind dramatische szenen aus
italien zeigen wir ihn gleich und
gleichzeitig so ein bisschen die
wettervorhersage für deutschland denn
das was wir im süden europas schon
gesehen haben das hat uns in der nacht
schon teilweise hier getroffen in bayern
in ostdeutschland in berlin auch in der
nacht und für die nächsten stunden
weiter heftiger heftiger regen angesagt
sie sehen hier bilder aus deutschland
aus ostdeutschland und süddeutschland in
bayern vor allen dingen da soll es ganz
ganz heftig wüten in diesen stunden und
auch in den nächsten also auch dort
überflutungs überflutungsgefahr vor
allen dingen weil die böden die sind so
ausgetrocknet dass sie kaum noch etwas
aufnehmen können und jetzt springen wir
dann eben noch mal zurück nach südeuropa
nämlich in die toskana nach piombino von
dort ebenso dramatischen bilder ein
riesenrad dort nicht nur vom regen
erfasst sondern von einem tornado
valentina wenn man das sieht als herz
installieren wie kommentiert man das
wenn ich jetzt in italien wäre und ich
glaube die berliner vor ort würden auch
sagen mama mia markt carola man würde
sich wundern was das überhaupt ist ich
kann mich gut erinnern wir sind zu
meinen kind zeiten immer etwas gerade in
den urlaub geflogen und da wenn es
stürmt stimmt richtig na also das sieht
man auch an diesen bildern das ist echt
kein spaß und da sollte man sich auch zu
hause einsperren im wahrsten sinne des
wortes und nicht rausgehen dass die
ligurische küste dann ein paar kilometer
weiter dort am strand eben auch der
tornado einmal rüber und hat eine spur
der verwüstung der zerstörung hinter
sich hergezogen das also nach all der
sonne all der dürre all der trockenheit
jetzt unwetter mit starkregen und
tornado in italien an der ligurischen
küste und in der toskana
[Musik]